cuál es el perímetro de la siguiente
figura y acá abajo tenemos la figura y
nos piden que encontremos el perímetro
el perímetro de esta figura y el
perímetro es la distancia que bordea
todo el exterior de una figura así que
en este caso si voy caminando alrededor
del borde bueno no espera tal vez un ser
humano es muy grande pero si te imaginas
una pequeña y hermosa hormiga y esa
pequeña y hermosa hormiga va caminando
alrededor de todo el borde de esta
figura entonces lo que haya caminado es
el perímetro así que para encontrar el
perímetro lo que vamos a hacer es
encontrar cuánto mide este lado y
sumarlo con lo que mide este lado y
sumarlo con la que miden este lado y
después de tener la suma de todos
la 2 entonces tendremos el perímetro así
que empecemos podemos empezar aquí se
observa este lado de aquí este lado de
aquí tiene una longitud de 5 centímetros
por lo tanto lo voy a escribir aquí 5 ya
esto le vamos a sumar y ahora si nos
movemos por este lado de aquí por este
lado de aquí vas a ver que este tiene
una longitud de 3 centímetros así que a
esto le voy a sumar 3 y después si
cruzamos a esta otra distancia
déjeme ponerlo con otro color esta otra
distancia te vas a dar cuenta que es de
4 centímetros
a esto le vamos a sumar 4 centímetros y
ahora vamos a ir hacia abajo y si vamos
hacia abajo y vemos esta distancia de
aquí esta distancia de aquí puedes ver
que es de 4 centímetros así que hay que
agregarle otros 4 centímetros y bueno
ahora podemos fijarnos en él
borde inferior y este borde inferior si
observas tiene una longitud de 9
centímetros así que a esto le voy a
agregar 9 centímetros y después tenemos
este lado y no no tenemos este lado
etiquetado no tenemos cuál es su
distancia pero para encontrar el
perímetro necesitamos las distancias de
cada uno de los lados si la hormiga
camina por todo este borde
necesitamos saber la distancia completa
que camino entonces lo que podemos decir
es que bueno este lado de aquí medía 3
centímetros este lado de aquí media 3
centímetros por lo tanto voy a tomar la
misma distancia en este lado si te fijas
de aquí hasta acá vamos a ver que esto
también mide 3 centímetros también mide
3 centímetros
y si ahora nos fijamos en donde acaba
esta distancia de 3 centímetros y nos
vamos hasta abajo te puedes dar cuenta
que tiene exactamente la misma longitud
que este otro lado de 4 centímetros si
empezamos justo aquí y terminamos hasta
la parte de abajo entonces tenemos que
esta distancia de aquí va a medir 4
centímetros 4 centímetros así que
tenemos 4 centímetros más otros 3
centímetros de esta parte me da en total
un lado de 7 centímetros
entonces este lado mide 7 centímetros y
ahora lo podemos escribir aquí más 7
centímetros y entonces ahora ya sabemos
el total de todas las longitudes de los
lados que bordean a esta figura así que
si las sumamos vamos a encontrar el
perímetro bien ahora si empezamos por
aquí 53
8 y después tengo 44 44 también es 8 y
después tengo 9 7 y bueno 9 más 7 lo
podemos ver como 9 ya esto sumarle uno y
después sumarle 6 porque 16 7 y así es
más fácil porque nueve más uno es 10 + 6
es 16 entonces 9 7 es lo mismo que 16
muy bien y después 8 más
8 estos dos me dan 16 así que tengo 16
16 y cuánto es esto
bueno pues 6 + 6 es 12 déjenme
escribirlo aquí 12 ya esto le voy a
sumar 10 10 con este valor lo voy a
poner 10 + 10 una vez 10 más
otra vez 10 es lo mismo que 20 y ahora
sí tengo veinte más 12 lo cual es
exactamente lo mismo que 32 y si
estábamos hablando de centímetros
entonces son 32 centímetros entonces la
distancia total que caminar a la hormiga
a través de los bordes de esta figura o
el perímetro de la figura es de 32
centímetros y ya con esto acabamos